hey
hi gilad
good evening good evening
gilad and i did an episode together at
bentino massaro's shift into permanent
alignment retreat in costa rica
on how free will is god
and this is now the second time
we're talking
on the show
[Music]
we stopped describing our experience for
two to five seconds
the complete absence of symbolization
that's good no description
and just resting as
the timeless presence
as the creator
i really appreciated what hillary had to
say about this
she's been saying that the people of the
highest vibration they feel differently
on your nervous system
yes yeah
there's a
like a confirmation mechanism
like a sensors so
to speak that defies
to you
in this vibrational
potential in the other like the clarity
the lightness
yeah like how you call it a confirmation
mechanism
[Applause]
yeah it's like the level
of realization that you have is verified
by the nervous system
confirming that the person that you're
with recognizes
a similar realization about their true
nature that you do
and i actually realized after the
retreat that
i had contrast with people that didn't
realize their nature and that
the vibration and the
synchronization with the nervous system
wasn't as strong
and so that was good contrast to have
yeah so how is the other
[Music]
state filled
with the people oh yeah that's a good
question
that's a good question yeah
it feels like
more disharmony
it feels less coherent it feels like
less unconditional love
it feels like the mind and the ego
are because they are taking them
on a big
bundle of emotions and feelings and
turbulence then because of that then
they take on
their local surroundings
including the nervous system of other
people onto
those same trajectories but
the people that have practiced they
don't go on those same
trajectories but they can tell that well
that
those trajectories weren't available to
me last week
because i was around a bunch of people
that had in a sense mastered
their energy and in this sense
now i'm exposed to people that haven't
mastered their energy
and that's why all of these timelines
are available
for this egoic contracted roller coaster
ride into emotions and
behavior patterns that are
not love light that's what it felt like
[Music]
and i know this experience i actually
experienced it recently also
here this contest after
spending the time with the
like-minded black-hearted
intention vibration and deliberateness
group of people which creates like this
unified field
in a sense which even if not physically
present together
all the time this field is like
is binded through the intention and to
this choice to come into this power
together into this separation and this
confidence vibration and confidence but
then
you know stepping out of that and then
mixing in the
in the soup of
just people just you know
people that come and go and do the
things
so then the this difference you
described was definitely
felt like very much
what i observed is also how i sort of
lower myself or i mean get with this
field
and in a sense it's like seeing how
one can become that field right
without enough will
to take the shape of this field you know
i took the shape to some extent of this
field
and and lowered my
vibration so to speak or like my my the
intensity of my
focus and the perfect heal and the
clarity not to say
i didn't still radiate
er
you know and
it was that also what i am
but there is this element of like
feeling
more dense yeah
more dense so for me it's like another
reflection there is
there is work to do there is like
gaps gaps to bridge
this gap of like a low vibration and
have a question
this dependence also on on this or that
so then the question came up like a few
minutes ago when we started
or a bit before was
can you fall out
can you fall out can you fall out of
love or out of god
to lose to lose it because with
this beautiful powerful vibrational
elevation and high
and clarity and then suddenly oh
oops where is it
um it's gone oh it's
like not so consistent
am i anything
so it's a question it's not like uh
you know this this question can be used
also like as a philosophy
like sometimes in the new adventure like
i'm i'm already perfect
i cannot lose anything or so like in
that way i'm not using it that way i'm
using it
as a way to bring light to the moment
and sort of quantum leap
back into the high vibration
the high density
not believing in this statement oh i
lost it
it's like the subtle discernment of
seeing observing the dynamics of energy
and the play
and the play of the energies
i think in the reality of it the
substance of it in the unbelieving my
identity
is is locked and contained
but then there's again like mastering
my energies or mastering being the
master of
the mind or therefore of what appears or
not not the master
but
having responsibility for
what appears
together with this wisdom of knowing
that clarity has nothing to do with what
appeals
like clarity is the
innate aspect in
existing in in saturn
so then it's like bringing this game
this simultaneous
intel interwine game of
we can also call it fourth and fifth
density
the evolution of the mind the liberation
of the mind also
out of the collective
sticky conditioning and
and vibrational cool you know the
collective is like
fools just pulls this gravitational pull
in a sense
evolution through the liberation of the
mind of the energies
and then on the other
hand or simultaneous together is the
what is referred to in my opinion is
fifth density which is the wisdom to
know
the timeless perfection of of all
appearances and of
everyone and the innate
unity in everything so
in that solution it's all it's perfect
there's only this timeless moment
which is seamless made of seamless
intelligence
see so this is like the these two games
which imagine the one in the uh
stages adapted
beautiful yeah there's a unified
container that we were in that was very
ascensionary and very pure and very
reflective and very abiding as
our true nature about three weeks ago
in costa rica and then about
two weeks ago we venture out of that
container
and into the stickiness
of the matrix the very 3d
style third density humans
government civilization economics
politics and propaganda
the media fast food high fructose corn
syrup
yeah all of that and
there's a lot of people's nervous
systems
are conditioned by those
more dense matrix stickinesses
and then we when we leave that sort of
vibration of truth when we when we make
contact with the matrix
again there's so much
stickiness the matrix tries to re-glue
on to us
but that the more wisdom
that one has the more they're able to in
a sense
see that
i'm not here to just go and martadom
into the matrix and
bring love into everybody's hearts in
the matrix
but rather it's sort of like this wise
like
okay that was actually a big part of my
trajectory after leaving the container
was
in a sense with the whole shift into
permanent alignment
i had to renege a lot of my 2021
commitments
so i basically turned in a lot of my
equity a lot of my agreements
on my 2021 projects
because they no longer aligned with my
highest excitement
and so that was a very fifth density
style move with wisdom
was to turn in your equity
and distance yourself from what feels
like more
sticky nervous systems with the people
that you were engaging with at the end
of 2020 and at the beginning of 2021
that felt more sticky when i left and so
i was like i don't
want to build any more with
the 3d stickiness and so because of that
even though there were some 4d
vibrations fourth density vibrations
in there as well there was still too big
of a mix
the it was people that couldn't even
recognize their own emotional guidance
system
they hadn't even mastered their own
energy systems
their own thought streams they hadn't
even really entered into their own
thought streams as said sotapanya's
stream entry
and so taking that the vibrations of
what was in the container
at the retreat and only architecting
with just
people that know themselves to that
degree became a priority and so that's
where i started really following the
highest excitement the breadcrumb trail
and it opened me up a lot it liberated
my
my time it liberated my energy
it liberated the conversations for me to
have are now
with more people that it feels good on
the nervous system
with
beautiful yeah yes so it sounds like
you become became
becoming uh more and more loyal
to to self-sufficiency to
to intuition you know these faculties of
wisdom
of trusting the self
you know being invested in death
which is which is
in that in that sense is the wholeness
is this
invincible in this invisi invisible
transparent field of internal energy on
intelligent infinity
so then yourself like
giving up to death entering to death
relying on that
that's an act of amplifying the wisdom
amplifying
sourcefulness amplifying the
you know the knowing that you can trust
your intuition you can trust this
like inner self-sufficient source for
energy
and put aside for a moment like this
this drive to to change and to
to be available
for others perfect and maybe also it has
to do with the investment
in the surface so sacrificing some of
that also
which keeps simplifying this the wisdom
you know seeing
that your self-esteem is built on this
like this conviction your agreements and
how they
appear to be and how you appears to be
and how you even
uh you know deliver
so to speak like even if you are doing
amazing and you're bringing like this
light shining forth you know
still it's like in in a sense tell me if
i'm wrong it's like
pale next to this inner knowing of
nothing matters nothing matters because
now i'm choosing
the this is the highest excitement and
this is the highest service also
it would be like this you and i having a
conversation
and then out of out of the blue i would
have a emotion that would arise
and feel like maybe i'm
having a confusing moment for myself
about who i
am and what i'm doing here and then i
would project that into our
conversation and into the environment
and i would start creating that
stickiness and it would drive the people
around me
mad because like you because you're
already at a high enough
resonance consciousness-wise of your
true nature
that you can you bypass this level that
i'm talking about
where you no longer see
a cloud come up on the screen and then
become attached to the cloud and then
have the cloud become
your vibration and then share that cloud
of
an emotion around unworthiness or
something to
everybody around you and that's why you
mentioned also
while you were talking that sat or truth
or existence
as said in in sanskrit the beginning of
satchitananda is always present and it's
always with us
but it's the undercurrent of what our
experience
is and we're just not subtle enough
to recognize that that's the
undercurrent and for example right now
i can't create anymore i can't
architect anymore i can't design
civilization
anymore i can't join into
entrepreneurial endeavors anymore
with people that have not fully communed
with sat the underlying current
sachit existence consciousness bliss
truth consciousness bliss
that you have to have fully communed in
a union
yoga with god with the absolute
in order for me to be able to create
with you now
that that that's the new standard that's
the new shift into alignment
for for me and that's why you also
called it a
you know a sourcefulness as well
nice so this this communion it is
like you know it's like
there's no like certain detector that
tells you
you said that the nervous system was
like the detector
it was like movement yeah i mean
my question is is the standard is about
like
someone who just initially maybe
has like this knowledge of this
faculty or this set you know because
you can have a revelation and so
a knowledge of that and you can have
like
which will be which will be known
but then you can have a deeper you know
it gets deeper and different
so i think it has to be at those depths
yeah at the depths in order to create
together at this point we did this shift
into permanent alignment
not so that we would come back and
create with people that had only tasted
the truth but to shift into permanent
alignment to
only build with people that had tasted
the truth
or that had that are fully embodied
gnostic beings of the truth
on a moment-to-moment basis because
that's why when bentino and the team
talk about
if you're gonna if you build with people
that aren't
shifted into that permanent alignment
guess what happens
holes holes in the ship happen
because people become obsessed with
needing to share their point of view
i am now righteous because i'm stuck
in personhood so i have to share my
point of view
because i don't understand that you're
the same love white
that i am i can't architect with people
that don't understand that they're the
same love light
that's the point that it's at now and i
think that's the shift into permanent
alignment for me and many others
is is that serious and
that's what's going to prevent holes
from being made in the ship
that's what's going to ensure that the
level of trust is at the absolute
highest
yeah i understand you
yeah it is like a it is a ground for
for everything basically i yeah i agree
or draw
something
the it's in a sense it's one side of the
coin
as i see it in this shift in alignment
just in alignment
or within a alignment so
what's the other side so in a sense that
completes it they complete each other
but i see them
as differently a bit so the other side
is
transparency transparency it's the
transparency
of the mind through
the fact that
it is let's say limited condition and
messed up so then
from that point it can always open up
or admit it's full of [ __ ] or like i'm
full of [ __ ] or i don't know
and then this is this is how evolution
and liberation can happen
yeah the like the
the sick perspectives or the misaligned
perspectives
then they can evolve into two
perspectives and and
being in line with with a certain
mission or a certain intention
but then in that in that way in that
sense it's as i said it's not absolutely
necessary for someone to be like
very very very deep in possession or in
self-sufficiency here's the question to
answer it
because you look at it this way
is your service
to maximize people moving from 3d
third density to fourth density because
the vast majority
of what i feel like around
sort of global enlightenment is really
trying to get people
out of person consciousness into unity
consciousness into that love
which is that kind of fourth density and
and um to optimize
the architectures in order to get there
to maximizing the amount of people that
go from third density to fourth density
to maximize it i feel like we can't
go and architect with people in like
three point five and four
but i feel like we have to architect
with people in five and six
in order to actually efficiently move
more
more more people from three to four does
that make sense
yeah okay cool totally
yeah it was just a point that felt
important because
because still you know this journey is
like alignment is like this
yeah so
there is a process and the process is
taking time so
most important is like the treatment to
the process
the intention the commitment the
consistency the vigilance
on on this inspiration exciting
integrity you know
so then so then this this also of
gaining more self-knowledge or deeper
self-knowledge
also happens by itself to this process
you know it's
each person each being it's it's
different and
the nuances and the subtleties from what
i've seen are different so
as i say committed to the journey and
have also like
sorry the stable knowledge of themselves
of this immediate
field of isness or fearness of
sat
of liberating and evolving the mind
and thus being able to be transparent
and being part of
a team or part of association with
others
relationship and relationship romantic
friendship you know
the ability to come from a space of
transparency of non-drama of
remembering why we are here why we are
playing this game
what's what's the purpose of it and you
know what comes also to mind is like the
the the example of the team of bentino
which from what i've seen from my
observation you know
i'm not saying anything like personally
about them but not everyone they are
like
very very deep into severalization
or hasn't been you know it's they're
also on the process
they're also they're not six density
beings
you know so and still they find
just an example that comes into mind
about like how it's it's also part of
the seat of comparison okay
each one has this process and that's
also fifth density
everyone in the process everyone has it
it's the time so it's this patience
this allowance for the flower to open up
you know or the food to become ripe
while having also the the sensor tells
you okay
this this person
is what it feels like he's coming from
truth but
but it's not like like
he has this thing what's their purity
for the people that are here you know to
to remember that
each one still while we come together in
whatever setting
we just lost you for a second but you're
back now
and it sounds like what what what
another way to phrase what you're saying
was
around purity as well yes purity is a
good is a good way to put it
yes because you're gonna have you're
gonna have these situations with the
nervous systems
and there's gonna be a detection of sort
of what density
the person is at and then further is
even if somebody is
at a higher density that's beyond let's
say
love maybe they're balancing out with
wisdom
is to just figure out well how pure
is it because where is it coming from is
it coming
from a place of wanting validation
right and so or is it coming from a
place of really true
just service to other people balanced
intelligently with wisdom
and being god and seeing god in other
people
so even if you've in a sense evolved to
a fourth density style understanding
or beyond you might not truly see
god everywhere always and
not try and be extracting from it so you
might shift down to
some third density matrix vibes
occasionally
yes yes i get to
also i just wanted to say that gina and
hillary are ready for us to do another
session
with them so i think this could be an
interesting place to potentially start
with them because hillary's quote is
about those nerve the nervous system
could be a good place to start together
yeah and so i just finished and i said
that you know
eventually when we had played this this
game of evolution and the
coming together copper and creating and
all of that stuff it's
human game in a sense so
so here what matters is the integrity
and transparency
in purity in that sense so
this the the self knowledge self
knowledge which
it's like saying like the thieves
definitely understanding the
iteration into sat is
like a prerequisite it's like a ground
for network
it's like a ground for detachment
for for for for this transparency it's
enables it amplifies it
empowers this ability to come together
and to play
want to create you know and whatever you
want to navigate in
into so then in that sense as i said
like
as long as there is this ground to some
extent
and there's it the being doesn't have as
i said
doesn't have to be like super super
super
realized uh like a super yogi you know
detached like fully because
still very likely people have the human
baggage you know the logo chakras maybe
and stuff which which are deep
but this level of transparency enables
what
you whatever comes you know things can
come
up to really like stand strong and and
and get into this stuff and staying with
discomfort
within yourself or maybe with others or
so
and going on and going on
from that perspective it's like again
it's like the understanding of
knowing
that it's like this radar as i said is
is about like the
the entire being you know it's like
doesn't it's not a certain
element
you know it's like you know it you know
you know the person and then and then
also the person is bullying is being put
into
test you know but then you know what i
mean
yeah it's like the colors really it just
feels
exactly it's just it's coming like from
you know that the third density is
coming from a place
that's a little bit more yellow and that
the fourth
is coming more and more from green
and whatnot and that that this kind of
how it how how it goes but
let's um okay let's wrap and get um
let's get gina and hillary in uh we'll
do a little uh uh chair with four legs
here in a moment i'm so pumped
and uh we'll bring you we'll bring you
lad back on because there's a lot of
good dynamic here
that i can tell is gonna be really
strong for moving forward and so
um gilad also had a recent
session with frank yang which was
awesome
and that i think we're also gonna do a
um a threesome together with frank
in about two weeks or so or so frank's
coming back on for episode two next week
so
we'll you'll see him back again soon
thanks everyone for tuning in
love you lots let us know how you feel
in the comments below the material we
were referencing throughout the
conversation is the law of one
go check out law of one dot info if you
want to go and check out more
information on the law of one
highly recommend reading that and that's
all let us know your thoughts in the
comments like the video if it brought
you value and share it with other people
subscribe if you haven't yet
adore you all thanks gilad you guys will
see us back live here in a moment with
uh
with hillary and gina so much love
i